[Music]
on this thursday night shattering
records for the wrong reasons
new covid cases hit all-time highs in
several provinces as hospitals brace for
an omicron onslaught a lot of people
will get exposed but emerging evidence
suggests that highly contagious variant
may be much less severe quarantine
questions i'm a little worried about
shortening isolation times why some
health workers exposed to kovid may
still have to report for duty the
verdict is in a jury reveals the fate of
a white police officer who killed a
black driver dante wright
and dubious distinction the high profile
people who made santa's naughty list and
we'll tell you which canadian just
dethroned the queen from the nice list
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with good news and
bad news in the fight against covid19
the good news the strongest indication
yet that omicron may be a much milder
variant of the virus a major analysis by
the uk health security agency found
people with omicron are up to 70 percent
less likely to end up in hospital
compared with previous variants similar
studies from south africa scotland and
denmark have all pointed to less severe
illness the bad news omicron is
spreading so fast that the sheer number
of infections could still lead to
hospitals becoming overwhelmed today
more than 20 thousand new cases were
confirmed in canada bc just smashed its
new daily case record for the third day
in a row in atlanta canada nova scotia
new brunswick and pei all set records
and the two most populous provinces
ontario and quebec are also reporting
all-time highs officials caution those
are likely vast under counts given the
backlog in testing
quebec remains canada's hot spot with
nearly 9 400 new cases that province is
hoping restrictions on gatherings and
businesses will help to turn things
around but as mike armstrong explains
it's also planning for the worst
there are two things quebecers need
right now to get a covid test a medicare
card and patience
testing facilities are operating at
capacity about 54 000 tests a day
critics say the official coveted numbers
may be sky high but they may also be
artificially low they should be doing
twice as much and we don't have the
staff for that we're not going to stop
vaccination to do more tests but you
have to remember that the 9000 is
probably a lot more in real life
one of the factors that may have made
quebec once again the country's hot spot
is its booster numbers it's in eighth
place nationally in terms of first and
second doses it's middle of the road
only 15 percent of the population is
unvaccinated that said they are very
over represented in hospital beds if you
actually look at montreal's data right
montreal's data shows that if you are
unvaccinated you're actually
three-quarters of the hospitalizations
now the health care system in quebec is
preparing for trouble hospitalizations
are rising in montreal more beds are
being dedicated to covet patients
surgeries are being cut and resources
are being moved around complicating
everything are doctors and nurses
catching covet the staff are getting
infected
every single day this week it's one or
two doctors here and there
one positive appears to be how sick
people are getting doctors say it's
still early but anecdotally it feels as
though this wave primarily omicron
is easier they're getting sick they're
making it to the icu
but they seem to also turn around
quicker
since the beginning of the pandemic
quebec has had some of the tightest
rules in north america that continues
essential businesses have been ordered
to close their limits on seeding and
hours at restaurants and for family
gatherings over christmas it's allowing
up to 10 people but as of boxing day the
limit will be cut to six despite all
those measures the province's optimistic
models for the next month predict
hospitalization numbers similar to the
worst wave of 2021. the pessimistic
models are worse
mike armstrong global news montreal
an omicron's rapid infection rate is
forcing officials across the country to
rethink self-isolation protocols with
the growing number of canadians catching
kovid coupled with their close contacts
essential services and businesses are
worried that they could be left short
staffed jamie morocco on the tough
choices facing some hospitals
contact with a covid case is no longer
uncommon in ontario
and it was unavoidable for professor and
family physician keena bracken when her
husband tested positive i was able to
completely isolate from him
and
you know wear my mask if we have to she
hasn't contracted the virus and while
she says she's been able to keep up with
her patients in residence there's
concern among her community omicron will
cause chaos if you have
all of a sudden all your health care
workers off because there is potentially
an exposure and who's going to work
who's going to take care of
covid patients and non-cova patients
with more mild breakthrough cases of the
highly transmissible variant expected in
the coming weeks quebec's largest health
care union says the government is
considering an aggressive plan
allow asymptomatic covet 19 positive
hospital workers to stay on the job
assigned to already infected patients
in the u.s biden's chief medical advisor
dr anthony fauci hinted it is also
considering reevaluating isolation
guidelines for health care staff while
back at home in ontario it will now
allow nurses and doctors who are exposed
to someone with covet 19 to continue
work as long as they test negative
instead of shutting everything down
we're being a lot more pragmatic saying
it's a different world we have high
rates of vaccination we're not seeing an
influx of of hospitalizations
and this is a way of letting people move
on with their lives in england
self-isolation rules have been shortened
for everyone from 10 to 7 days as long
as they test negative twice in a row the
smart family from toronto is a week into
their christmas quarantine after a close
contact last thursday since both amy and
colin have tested positive i'm a little
worried about shortening isolation times
when testing is so tough to come by dr
bracken agrees it's another hurdle
provinces will have to overcome things
have changed over the course of time and
it's really hard to adapt to change as
rapidly as we need to
fortunately in the era of omicron time
is a luxury officials just don't have
jamie morocco global news toronto
the u.s is also seeing record covid 19
cases driven by omicron at a time when
many hospitals there were already
struggling to keep up with the delta
variant an average of 168 000 cases are
now being reported every day that's
nearly 40 percent more than just a
couple of weeks ago hospitalizations are
also up by 11 percent as jackson proskow
reports the surge has sparked
overwhelming demand for rapid tests and
new treatments
demand for covid testing has outstripped
supply
hard to find rapid tests are now the
must-have item for the holidays as
millions of americans weigh whether they
can gather safely we've both possibly
been exposed to people in the past
couple of days who have coveted and the
rapid tests the home tests are
impossible to find
the testing crunch comes as cities and
states shatter records for daily case
counts in washington d.c cases are up
nearly 400 percent in a week there's a
lot we don't know in an interview with
abc news president joe biden suggested
there was no way to have prepared how
did you get it wrong
how do we get it wrong nobody saw it
coming
nobody in the whole world who saw it
coming
already strained hospitals are now
bracing for a potential omicron fueled
surge that could also sideline doctors
and nurses it's really the unknown
we are in a perfect storm it's not clear
how the new variant will impact the
large number of unvaccinated americans
former president donald trump is
appealing to his often hesitant
supporters to reconsider the ones that
get very sick and go to the hospital are
the ones that don't take the vaccine
there is some new hope for those who
might become severely ill the fda
approved a second at-home coveit
treatment the anti-viral pill made by
merck is less effective than a similar
treatment from pfizer
it all comes too late to stave off major
holiday disruptions new york will now
scale back new year's eve in times
square mandatory masks and fewer people
the year as it began with kovitt driving
caution
jackson prosko global news washington
in china a city of 13 million people is
now under snap lockdown after an
outbreak of covid 19. all residents of
the northern city of xi'an are barred
from leaving their homes except to buy
essential items no one is allowed in or
out of the city unless given permission
so far 127 cases have been
detected south korea meanwhile has just
set a new record for daily covid19
deaths today 109 deaths were reported
and more than a thousand people were in
hospital with serious symptoms south
korea has been grappling with a major
surge in cases after relaxing
restrictions in november tough measures
have since been reimposed
in the u.s a police officer who said she
mistook her gun for a taser has just
been found guilty in the shooting death
of dante wright a jury has convicted
49-year-old kim potter on two counts of
manslaughter she shot and killed wright
a 20-year-old black man during a traffic
stop in minneapolis in april potter said
at the time she thought she had grabbed
her taser potter now faces a maximum
sentence of 15 years behind bars
libya's election suspension coming up
why the war-torn country's first
presidential vote has been postponed
amid fears of fighting
[Music]
in libya voters were supposed to go to
the polls tomorrow in a much anticipated
presidential election but after months
of disputes over the rules and
candidates that vote has been delayed
one of those running is the son of
former libyan leader omar gaddafi the
dictator was killed in an uprising a
decade ago and the country has been in
turmoil ever since as redmond shannon
reports there are now fears the looming
election could trigger more bloodshed
the 2011 capture and killing of muammar
gaddafi was meant to signal a new
beginning for libya after 42 years of
his authoritarian rule but within three
years the oil rich nation descended into
civil war two parallel governments and
smaller militias fighting for control
one side loosely backed by the un with
support from turkey and qatar the other
led by army commander khalifa haftar
supported by egypt and russia we have
lost a lot of hope you cannot imagine
these 11 years besides no electricity no
water but when you see people actually
being killed houses being burned down
war is not an easy thing
some violence has continued since the
2020 truce brokered by turkey and russia
since then an interim government has
chaotically shepherded libya toward this
presidential vote the elections are ripe
not for democracy or democratic
transition but essentially a return to
authoritarianism and the reasons for
that are the number of electoral legal
and political disputes on the ground
firstly interim prime minister and
former qadhafi ally abdul hamid daba
promised he wouldn't run in the election
but he changed his mind
he's widely reported to have studied at
the university of toronto but u of t has
no record of anyone of his name
graduating
secondly in recent months courts
sentenced half dart to death and
excluded him from running for president
only for haftar to be allowed to enter
the race on appeal and a third leading
candidate the son of muammar gaddafi
safe al-islam was also barred from
entering but he had that overturned too
speaking with the new york times this
year he framed himself as a bringer of
stability but said little on policy safe
had been imprisoned for war crimes and
just this month the international
criminal court reminded the world that
he is wanted for alleged crimes against
humanity and he is certainly
an ideological lightning rod in libya he
he really does cut right down the
dividing line between those that want to
transition towards a democratic and an
equitable libya um and those that just
want to see it run by
you know certain tribes and certain
members of the of libya's communities
that may
ride in first class in an authoritarian
boat whilst leading everyone else in
coach there are dozens of candidates
including others who've spent time in
canada analysts say as long as foreign
powers continue to have a military
influence in libya the country will
remain divided and ultimately lawless
what's very important that we have to
take back this legitimacy that we have
given to these militias to these
criminals libya's outgoing united
nations mediator thinks the country
needs a vote as soon as possible as the
u.n security council remains divided on
its strategy for this troubled north
african nation redmond shannon global
news london
does plexiglas provide proper protection
from kovid and how can you safely
socialize with unvaccinated friends and
family over the holidays the experts
answer your covid questions after the
break
[Music]
we've heard growing calls from health
officials in recent days for people to
upgrade their masks to protect against
omicron but what exactly makes the mask
the right fit to answer that question
and others we've received from our
viewers over the past few days we are
joined now by infectious diseases
physician dr isaac bogash and
epidemiologist patrick saunders hastings
doctors thank you both so much for
joining us to tackle some of these
questions so isaac bogash first over to
you for those of us who put masks on our
christmas list this year fred wants to
know is mass quality more important with
omicron and what's acceptable and when
should a mask be discarded or washed
what do you think
yeah a couple of points here a higher
quality mask certainly is uh is more
important especially with omicron where
we have very little wiggle room uh as
this is a very transmissible variant uh
higher quality means something better
than a single layered cloth mask you
might hear words like n95 or kn95
it's thicker they've got less pores in
them and the key thing here is it's got
a tighter fit around around the nose and
around the mouth and that's really it a
good a tight fit around the face and a
higher caliber mask and 95 kn 95
sometimes you hear surgical masks as
well and again
these uh n95s and kn95s have usually a
much tighter fit than the surgical mask
too
yeah very good to know dr saunders
hastings over to you for the next
related question this one comes from
lisa who says that she works in an
office with several people sitting next
to each other not wearing masks but
there are plexiglass barriers in between
them does plexiglas help protect against
omicron it does help protect i think
like masks plexiglass can be a tool in a
tool set of preventing transmission but
i think like masks they are not
foolproof and then they are not 100
effective and so i think
we're often better served considering
plexiglas is part of a broader suite of
transmission prevention protocols
including masks and so i think when
we're talking about office settings
depending on the crowded nature the
ventilation
other protocols in place
plexiglas may or may not be sufficient
but it certainly doesn't hurt and it can
help to prevent transmission
okay uh dr bergash back over to you for
this next question that comes from judy
an interesting one she says if someone
has kovid but doesn't know it perhaps
they're asymptomatic and then they go to
get a vaccine
how will that affect them will the
vaccine work
yeah this is uh this is actually a
remarkably common uh issue sometimes
people get the vaccine in close
proximity to a covet 19 infection they
didn't know they were infected or they
might have been incubating the virus at
the time they got the vaccine uh in
general it's not we're not seeing any
any significant issues with this
whatsoever in a perfect world we would
usually vaccinate someone uh after
they've recovered from their infection
but if they do get a vaccine around the
time of infection we haven't seen any
issues with that
yeah interesting dr saunders hastings uh
speaking of vaccines and this is a
timely question of course comes from
carol who says that she has three
members of their small family group that
are not vaccinated and she's wondering
how to have them over in the household
for socializing and holiday dinner how
to do it safely right so certainly
vaccines are a safe and effective way of
preventing transmission and then we'd
absolutely encourage everyone to get
their vaccines as well as to consider
keeping your distance from unvaccinated
individuals
with that said
if you are not going to adhere to that
guidance i think again we can consider
vaccines as part of a broader suite of
transmission prevention tools and so for
those that are unvaccinated who will be
seeing others
you could consider isolating before that
gathering you could
do rapid testing in advance of that
gathering you could wear a mask you
could distance at that gathering
so i think there's a lot of
non-pharmaceutical interventions that
can still help reduce that risk
though it will be higher by by gathering
with unvaccinated individuals relatives
to vaccinated ones
yeah helpful information for a lot of
families certainly over the next few
days patrick saunders hastings dr isaac
bosergosh thank you both so much for
taking the time really appreciate it
thank you
my pleasure
and we'll be putting your questions
about omicron to the experts again
tomorrow so please send us yours to your
questions at globalnews.ca
next naughty or nice who's on the wrong
side of canada's christmas list
[Music]
some sad news out of the u.s tonight
journalist and author joan didion has
died in the 1960s didion emerged as a
distinct voice in u.s literature her
work includes the year of magical
thinking and the white album in 2012 she
received a national humanities medal
from then president barack obama and was
praised for devoting her life to
noticing things other people strive not
to see didion was 87.
well if you have kids you've probably
spoken to them about santa's naughty
list if nothing else it's a great way to
get them to do chores in december but
there's another list out today that
asked ordinary canadians to rank profile
people as naughty or nice and as mike
drolet tells us you might be surprised
who made the list
ah christmas a time filled with laughter
and joy family get-togethers and the
shame of being on the wrong side of
santa's naughty or nice list
well
here it is
and it's magic not to be outdone by
santa our friends at ipsos came up with
their own list or rather canada's list
this year it's topped by a russian
conflict
so what gives canada why does vladimir
putin top your naughty list
maybe it's because if there are hockey
rivals maybe because of the cold war
maybe because of whatever but the leader
of russia is not seen as a particularly
positive person by canadians oddly
enough justin trudeau comes in a close
second to putin which could be seen as
either an affront to trudeau or putin
i guess it shouldn't be that surprising
to see so many politicians like ontario
premier doug ford make the list in these
polarizing times or billionaires for
that matter
who would have been celebrated a decade
ago for their ingenuity but now jeff
bezos and mark zuckerberg are seen as
evil tech geniuses but enough with who's
naughty in the eyes of canadians
let's talk about nice and is it any
surprise healthcare workers top the list
ensure dr teresa tam greta tunberg
sidney crosby and dr anthony fauci all
have varying degrees of nice in them and
justin bieber is equally naughty and
nice in her eyes which makes sense as
well
but there's a new addition who has done
the unthinkable and knocked the queen
off her perch you know i've been doing
this for many many years for parentally
topped the list like the queen uh does
really well on this but ryan reynolds
even does better than the queen
yeah canada loves ryan reynolds
and why wouldn't we he's funny nice and
charitable but if there's anything to
learn from these lists it's this he
should enjoy the throne for now
who knows what next year will bring
mike roley global news toronto
congratulations deadpool that is global
national for this thursday night i'm
jeff semple tonight's your canada is
this very festive truck in carstairs
alberta please keep sending us your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]